what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we're doing our episode of too
powerful for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and my girlfriend Mariah is
here say hi Mariah okay so so too
powerful for the mobile cinema news okay
pros yet alright we've talked about
protege like a million times before so
we have to cover we have to cover the
character project alright so Marvel mama
has a hierarchy of powerful people Riley
you have one above all all the way the
very top and then you've got like the
beyonders who I would put write it below
the one above all cuz they kill the
Living Tribunal they need a little tribe
you'd only got like the custodian the
multiverse so on and so forth now these
are all beings who are powerful in their
own right because their power calls for
it most beings that Marvel comics are
powerful because they have a predefined
set of powers which manifested at some
point in time and as a result of that
they can go forward and do things right
like Vulcan the third Summers brother
can manipulate every form of energy
Charles Xavier has telepathy the Phoenix
force is the sum total of all life that
has ever currently doesn't we'll ever
resist in the multiverse then you have
protege and protege was a character who
was created by the universal Church of
truth so why the clock back so what you
had here and Marvel Comics is you add
Adam warlock and most everybody knows
who Adam warlock is which is to say he's
basically like the Jesus equivalent of
Marvel Comics now the way that Adam
walks character was originally created
he was established by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and you had a group called The
Enclave and The Enclave was this
organization that basically sought to
conquer the world using technological
means they came into conflict with the
Fantastic Four but they created a
perfect being called him and when the
perfect being escaped it took off into
space
it tried to Mary SIF like Adam were
lacking for got into a battle for a
little while and then eventually Adam
warlock met the High Evolutionary and
High Evolutionary basically gave him the
soul stone and said your job is to go to
counter earth like a different earth
that orbits the moon and you have to
defeat man-beast who was an allegory for
Satan and then that led into you know
the whole story of Adam were like
becoming Christ anyway
when jim Starlin took over the character
of adam warlock which basically started
intertwining adam with like the story of
fan o's that what ended up happening was
there was a future version of Adam
called The Magus and the Magus is an
answer to the question what if Adam
warlock became a bad guy and so what the
Magus had done in the main Marvel
Universe is in the far-flung future he
created an organization called the
universal Church of truth and the
universal Church of truth served the
purpose of literally living to its
namesake which is to say like sweeping
across the universe and just conquering
world after world and conscripted
various people into its cause which was
to worship the Magus in his entire
treat him like a messiah and then just
do his bidding in an alternate reality
called earth 691 the whole story played
out the exact same way the difference
here is that the Magus never returned
and because the Magus never came back
the leaders of the universal Church of
Truth didn't really know how to respond
and so what they did is they basically
created their own leader like they're
their own Messiah of sorts which came in
the form of a protege and protege was a
little kid that had the ability to
duplicate the powers of everyone like
yeah he had the ability to duplicate the
powers of others and it was cool because
we've seen power mimicry in the past but
they're never really been an instance
where we see at least open to that point
where protege was introduced where we
had seen an instance of a character who
could duplicate the powers of others
with no upper limit when protege first
popped up protege basically sort of
duplicated the powers of the guardians
of the galaxy or at least guards the
galaxy 3000 this was back in so back in
91 back before the guardians that you
guys know now which were actually
created by Brian Michael Bendis you had
the guardians of the galaxy 3000 which
were just a future version of the team
and they fought alongside like for
different things like that protege
basically starts copying their powers
released a power the other powers those
are actually have abilities and then
starts expanding outward and so it's one
of these things where it's like over the
over the course of time no one knows how
to stop Protege because everyone who
goes towards and everybody who faces him
if they use telepathy he immediately
knows how to use telepathy if they use
energy projection you can copy their
interview projection powers if it's
somebody like who can warp reality he
can do the same thing this is when
things get kind of hairy because when
you start talking about powers like
reality manipulation and reality reality
altering then things get kind of weird
so the way this works in Marvel Comics
is you have two types of powers you have
passive powers and active powers passive
powers are powers that by whatever
manner in whatever means just activate
on their own so like Wolverines healing
factor is a passive power but someone
like Cyclops who has to actually open
his eyes or someone like Nightcrawler
who teleports that said that's an active
power they have to actually think about
doing it and activate that ability in
order to be able to use it with protege
it was a passive power to duplicate the
powers of others you combine that with
reality altering or or matter
manipulation so in Marvel one of the
things that people get confused all the
time about is is like reality wars right
so take Franklin Richards and then take
madam Jasper's so Franklin Richards can
just create things but it's only in a
universal space right like Franklin
Richards cannot adjust the multiverse
you can just tinker with an existing
universe but in in Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four
when child Franklin's powers were
restored by his future adult self he
created a universe in his bedroom and he
didn't do that by drawing on existing
matter from from the current universe he
literally just pulled it out of nowhere
so he can just kind of create something
out of nothing
those are reality war perks they can
just do whatever they want with the
fundamental fabric of the universe and
it goes from there then you have matter
manipulators and matter manipulators are
people who can only manipulate the
existing universe as its stamped so they
can't create something out of nothing
so like Majumdar's was like that we know
that because he was taken to a universe
where there was no matter and there was
just a normal guy and he was he was
ultimately destroyed protege is a is a
reality worker and because protege had
no upper limit to his powers what this
meant was that when the cosmic entities
faced him he duplicated all their powers
so they couldn't stop him it took the
Living Tribunal showing up even let me
Tribunal himself could not actually stop
protege
when the Living Tribunal showed up and
and started facing off against protege
courage they started copying his powers
like one after another and so he was
basically like this nine I'm nipa ten
kid and then declared himself as the new
one above all and and we would kind of
have to continue on that trend and say
if there was no upper limit to the
powers that he could duplicate but if
the one above all appeared then he'd be
able to count copy the powers of the one
above all now at that point you're
talking about two beings of equal power
because nothing is more powerful than
one above all if forever there was a
ceiling to the amount of power a beam
could have the one above all would be it
and so you're talking about two bees of
equal power like a battle like that
would just lay waste to the multiverse
in like the blink of an eye I mean
everything would just just cease to
exist
but um what what ended up happening is
in the story in order to write
themselves out Jim Valentino created
something called escape in the approver
and this is this is a solution so in
Marvel Comics and we're gonna go super
in-depth into this but in Marvel Comics
you have Celestials which were which
were at one point humanoid beings who
achieved like a super high level of
technology and basically like
transcended a physical form and became
like like beings of pure energy
so Celestials travel to the universe and
they basically somewhere along the line
where the universe started created life
the idea behind this is that they they
show up to a planet and they judge the
life on that planet and the guardians of
the galaxy story skated the approver was
introduced as like a universal judge and
so scape and the approver was either he
would even get like a thumbs up or a
thumbs down and the indication was that
nothing could happen in that universe
unless scathing the approver approved of
it or disapproved of it now in reality
the Living Tribunal never really seemed
to need the judgement of others in order
to decide whether or not something
needed to happen that was
long-established fact that the Living
Tribunal existed for the purpose of
maintaining magical energies in a
universe meaning you couldn't have liked
to doctor strangers or you couldn't have
liked to mistress deaths or like to
Eternity or something like that and so
when the Living Tribunal shows up to
judge for whatever reason which was
never fully explained it had to seek the
permission of scaping the approver in
order to decide what needed to happen
and skatin the approver judged against
against protege and then the Living
Tribunal just absorbed protege into
himself because there was nothing else
that could be done and so you take that
concept and you apply it to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and it's hopeless and
the reason why is because in marl in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe all the
characters serve a role Scarlet Witch is
the magical side alongside Doctor
Strange Thor and and The Incredible Hulk
er like the heavy hitters Iron Man is is
the brains of the operation and Captain
America just runs in like he can punch
kind of part like different characters
have different roles to play but again
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
always been grounded has always been
like what if superheroes existed in the
real world and so when you when you
start throwing in characters more exotic
powers it does make things more
interesting because say for example
Thanos gothy got the Infinity Gauntlet
and then once ago fights were to go
fight protege then protege would
basically adapt to the powers the
Infinity Gauntlet which means a protege
would develop reality warping
time-travel being able to read minds on
a universal scale all those things would
come together and he would basically
become a walking talking Infinity
Gauntlet or at least he would have
enough power to rival that of the
Infinity Gauntlet and then if you said
Santos showed up with like the heart of
the universe it would be the exact same
thing look at power the one above all so
you're talking about taking a character
whose power is to literally duplicate
all the powers of everyone he sees with
no upper limit if anything it would be a
stalemate you know now that's okay
that's kind of the crazy question
because say for example the protege
would have duplicate the powers of the
Hulk right like like reality warping and
energy projection and all that kind of
stuff is is a whole different beast and
and and it works it works because I'm
sorry is distracting me right now it
works because it works for protege
because manipulating reality is
manipulating reality being able to
duplicate things like that is is what
have you but if Protege were to be able
to duplicate the powers of the Hulk
would it be the exact same way like the
Hulk gets stronger than angrier who gets
if protege duplicates that does he does
he automatically have like the upper
limit to the Incredible Hulk power is he
just automatically that strong you know
and is he just infinitely stronger I
mean I don't know like those are weird
little questions that you have but the
long and short of it still remains
if Protege popped up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and sort of facing
off against all their all the characters
do be nothing they can do the only
person that I would say might be able to
stand a chance against him would be
Doctor Strange and this is kind of a
caveat the reason why is because Doctor
Strange in and of himself actually has
no powers all Doctor Strange does is is
use spells to manipulate the powers of
others which become which really kind of
begs the question would protege if he
faced off against Doctor Strange be able
to basically duplicate doctor Strange's
knowledge of the magical spells that he
has at his disposal and if he can and he
be able to be Doctor Strange but
assuming that he cannot duplicate the
knowledge of others Doctor Strange would
win but if he could duplicate the
knowledge of others Doctor Strange would
lose because again he's really the only
person with powers but uh but ya know I
don't you know it would be cool to see
protege T in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but honestly that'd be a short
might be like a one-shot movie I mean
something like that like protege the
beyonders Thanos with the heart of the
universe um the original Beyonder and
like the molecule man Owen Reese or like
Doctor Doom during Doom War when he
invaded what condo so all the vibranium
and like amplified as magical power I
mean like characters like that and
powers like that those are in time
stories like those are stories like like
you'd have to pick one of those when
you're gonna like wind down the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and end it that's one
of the characters that you pick you know
the kind of end everything either that
or somehow it all gets reset back I
don't really know let me know you guys
things out in the comment section anyway
if you are new here to come let's
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you